can i ask you a question and this is
actually for the both of you
it's
i mean you love america more than maybe
anybody i know and you weren't born here
you've been very explicit that i'm
on american i don't even use a hyphen do
you think immigrants who have left other
countries
appreciate and love america more than
natural born citizens no doubt listen i
was walking uh for
about 10 minutes outside and
in this city here and as i'm looking
left and right and i'm looking oh my god
we're such a rich country
it is totally amazing because
and immigrants like me
we know where we came from and
there wasn't much there
and and opportunities are everywhere if
you want to take advantage of the
opportunities
um and the one thing that unfortunately
is
not playing as big a role as it should
is that i mostly admire as to you as
constitution i i took a college course
i've been like
multi-session course about the
constitution
absolutely brilliant document we're
talking about we're talking about uh
how they uh constructed the government
so that minorities would be protected
as opposed to when you have a democracy
if you if you have 51 of the votes you
can do whatever you please and you can
really run roughshod the over the 49
so yeah it's incredible structure on how
they had it i mean
hillary clinton and some other people
want to change it
uh to a different model but you're right
the structure is a you know what he
means by minorities he doesn't mean
minorities like ethnicity wise mind 49
yeah pat where did your love for america
really manifest
uh
listen you know again you have to
sometimes you appreciate a friend when
you have a bad friend sometimes you
appreciate a girl when you have a
bad experience with another girl
sometimes you appreciate a guy you date
based on a different bad experience you
have some of the best things that can
ever happen to you is something bad
that makes you realize listen
it's time to be super grateful what were
you complaining about so
the challenge with america america has a
gratitude problem that's what it is
america's got purely a gratitude and a
perspective problem those two things is
what's hurting america more than i can
tell you uh we lack gratitude we
complain too much we act like victims
and we don't realize that this is the
greatest country in the world still
and uh
rather than doing something with
everything that's given to you you
complain about it that's the biggest
thing with me this is the greatest
country there but go back to them can i
chime in just
with one with one
thing i want to say americans right
not all but a large majority of
americans are either fat dumb and happy
or fat dumb and angry
we're fat we're the the most overweight
nation of this in the civilized world 36
percent overweight
um
we we have dumbed down at least two
generation of of young people because
we're not teaching critical thinking
anymore
and uh depending you either we're either
happy because we you know we we love
entertainment sports and the tv and
binge watching and all that and then we
get angry
uh
when things don't work when we we we
curse at each other in social media
that's that's a this is a systemic issue
in society
that doesn't seem to have a good outcome
if we don't find a way to
no i agree with you it's a very weird
dynamic the other day westbrook is
complaining because somebody called them
westbrook
and everybody's coming out and saying
well it's not fair to talk to the person
like that what whatever happened to
you know sticks and bones you know
yeah so whatever happened to you know
people can call you anything you want to
go complain about 40 million dollar your
income okay while you're going to your
nice house people are sitting trying to
make 50 60 crane a year
and they're really having to go through
problems you're worried about somebody's
calling you westbrook because you're not
practicing you're not shooting free
throws well i'll give you one anecdote
that sings um to your story it's you
know i went to uh the freedom forum on
behalf of uh no gary kelsey gary
kasparov invited me i'm sure you're very
familiar with gary kasparov
um greatest chess player uh to ever live
and i interviewed a lot of essentially
freedom fighters the one iranian lady
that you know with the big hair
and the um
gentleman that i interviewed from
iraq he basically hosts the daily show
in iraq
to put it in perspective he's like a
comedian satirist
um
political pundit uh funny guy and to
your point about being you know fat lazy
and happy or
fat lazy and angry and watch you brought
up reality tv and just sitting around
and just whatever he said i wish i go
what's your your one wish if you could
for the people of iraq i wish that we
could just sit around and watch reality
tv and that's what i wish for the iraqi
people meaning
that there's so much drama and so much
conflict and so much tyrannical abuse
going on that they can't even just sit
down and watch tv for a half hour and
just watch mindless [ __ ]
and that's what happens here in america
is that we make our problems so much
deeper than they really are compared to
what's going on in the actual real world
to use a real world uh the problem that
with
america sometimes is that they're
too consumed with entertainment and not
enough comes consumed with
you know uh
education after graduating from high
school or college education stops for
most people in america
not most people in america period most
people right the moment they stop going
to college or they go to high school
they don't read books anymore they don't
finish books or romance novels let me
see the best movie let me see the best
this let me see the best that so
entertainment
has a has
sucked probably 40 50 percent of most
people's lives where they won't
you know put enough time but at the same
time that is one of our greatest exports
i don't rock and roll entertainment no
no no no american culture you're talking
to a guy who loves music who's excited
about elvis documentary coming out who
no i totally get it but i think there's
also an element of uh of being a little
bit more educated about history of
what's really going on that's what i
mean by that absolutely i mean i i now
run into people younger people you know
late teens or early 20s what whoa kgb
what's that
you know the biggest war in history
world war ii and again
and this the mass murder that happened
in
in the last century
people don't know yeah and
if they don't know
they might not see it coming
it's not
totally
uh out of the question that united
states one day becomes a dictatorship
happened in germany so if you enjoyed
this little segment from the podcast
click over here to watch the entire
podcast and if you've not subscribed to
the channel please do so take care
everybody
[Music]